by the way mvl our co- tournament leader
has lost to Wesley and Bishop takes a
this game is going and that Bishop on A8
is alive what does it mean it means what
oh the the G Pawn just got chopped off I
was about to say Bishop goes back to D6
Pawn goes to G3 Bishop C8 Bishop B7 an
idea here absolutely but it stopped with
the King coming to C6 could play B7
check first and then Rook G6 that maybe
was much stronger actually he can still
do it now it's drawn after you can yeah
take twice yeah I don't know why we're
taking these massive amounts of risks as
Anish maybe Ste still no now you can't
take there's G6 in the end G6 wins and
Anish realizes it oh and he resigns but
oh what a game he threw away a half a
point there at the end absolutely uh
Peter a very very eventful round